and Roy Moore this is another another
series of scandals Roy Moore the
convenient GOP scapegoat that's the
topic of tonight's angle when it comes
to Roy Moore's Alabama Senate bid it
seems like everyone is running for the
exits and perhaps they should look the
accusations have piled up and I
understand no one running for office
wants to be asked uncomfortable
questions questions like do you support
Roy Moore with these allegations hanging
over his head do you believe Roy Moore
should even be seated
he's gonna hurt the party leaders say so
let's cut our losses now and put Jeff
Sessions back in his old seat it's going
to be a midterm election disaster for
the GOP but the more I think of it the
more I hear all this I kind of think the
GOP is just trying to use the more
allegations yeah use them to deflect
deflect attention and criticism from
their own failures if these accusations
are true that there'd be no place for
him in the Senate I hope that he steps
down immediately I mean this is I never
thought he belongs in the Senate I am
pleased to be able to see that the
nation though is talking about moral
issues and trying to hold leaders to a
higher account well I guess yes let's
hope that happens
but Roy Moore's future is going to
depend on the voters in Alabama and the
gops future is going to depend on their
own legislative record which let's face
it it's not too hot it's not too hot
with or without more check out this
congressional approval rating it's now
is about 15 percent only twenty nine
percent of all Americans have a positive
view of the GOP I mean Donald Trump's
looking really good compared to those
numbers and last time I checked let's
face it it wasn't Moore who dropped the
ball on Obama Obamacare repeal and he
didn't take long periods of time off out
of session while they had work to do he
didn't fail to support enforcement of
immigration laws Roy Moore didn't
support those absurd multilateral trade
agreements that hurt the American worker
he didn't cause Ron Johnson to come
against tax reform today and we know
this more didn't set up a slush fund for
congressional miscreants there were
involved with sexual behavior now that's
immoral Roy Moore will certainly hurt
the GOP image in 2018 he could if he's
elected and especially among some female
voters that'll hurt but before the GOP
makes him the scapegoat for all that
ails the party well I think the GOP
itself needs to do some self-reflection
what of Republicans done in the past to
infuriate and alienate their own base so
much so that they actually pushed Route
Luthor strange
out of the equation they decided to go
with Roy Moore and now what does the GOP
gonna do to try to build back its
reputation oh here's the good news no
matter what people say about Republicans
or the more sideshow at least they don't
have someone like this running around
[Applause]
he's 45
[Applause]
[Music]
does she know that doesn't rhyme at all
that's not a rhyming chant you see GOP
it can always get worse and that's the
angle